oh
I
we'll get to it
okay folks time to get started reminder
again that if you want to turn in your
discounted cash flow valuation for
feedback it's April 4th which is a
little while from now but there's a
spring break right in the middle so if
you're going to do some work it probably
has to be before spring
break but today I want to continue our
discussion of stories and numbers I
remember when I wrote my book narrative
and numbers about connecting to stories
numbers I got a lot of push back from
numbers oriented analysts and they said
we don't tell stories we work with
numbers and I said really you work with
numbers you don't think you're telling a
story so here's what I'd like you to do
I'm going to show you a discounted cash
flow value ation is all numbers and I
want you to reverse engineer the story
I'm telling from the numbers so here's
what I have in my spreadsheet I have a
50% compounded annual growth rate in
revenues for the next 10 years file that
away compounded annual growth rate 50% a
year second I'm assuming that this
company by the time it gets to year 10
will have a 20% operating margin which
is twice the average for the Industry
Group it
said third this company has a very low
reinvestment for the next 10 years I'm
using a high sales to Capital ratio and
finally I'm giving this company a cost
of capital of 7% in dollar terms lower
than the average cost of capital okay so
that's all you have a spreadsheet I'm
just going to ask you to guess what the
underlying story is first am I valuing a
small company or a large company you
think based on those
numbers and what may what's the clue
that it's a small company
50% compounded annual growth rate means
you're taking your company and
increasing it 100 fold that's what 50%
growth over the next 10 years is if you
have 20 billion in revenues right now 50
time 20 is a trillion dollars in Revenue
so clearly it's got to be a small
company is it a is the total Market that
it's going after growing or
stable because if it were stable how do
you get 50% compounded growth you got to
eat market share away and what's the
clue that that's not what they're doing
what's a margin what's a margin doing
it's twice a size so if you're going
after market share you're probably
competing on price you're competing on
price so the fact that you have 50%
compounded growth rate and 20% margin
suggests that the market must be growing
third are you telling me a story about
the competitive advantages that this
company has somewhere in there
sopia the margins are much higher
there's something they're doing that
allows them to charge higher margins
maybe a strong brand name maybe a
patent what about Capital intensity yeah
low and what is it that gives it away
the reinvestment is low so the capital
intensity is low and finally let's Crown
the whole story is this company selling
a product that is discretionary or
non-discretionary
and what is the clue you would look at
to answer
that it's non-discretionary and what is
the clue that gives that away
low amount of risk 7% cost to cap
remember when we talked about betas we
said if you have a non-discretionary
product so basically you're telling me a
story of a small company that's going to
grow explosively in a market that's big
and growing while having strong
competitive
advantages with low Capital intensity
and a non-discretionary product so when
you show me that spreadsheet I'm going
to read the story back to you and say
hey do you buy that story if you say I
don't like that story you're disagreeing
with yourself
try this out the next time you pick up
an Excel spreadsheet reverse engineer
from it cuz you cannot get away from
telling a story you can either leave it
implicit which is what a lot of analysts
do or make it
explicit so I'm going to pick on a
couple of you who pick companies to
value and use Brian you're valuing PDD
right so let's go through it part by if
you are telling a story for PDD in terms
of Revenue growth are you telling what
what kind of story big big high growth
low growth average growth back at up
high growth and what's the basis for
that
story
okay the only problem is us is a is a
mature market so you're going after
market shares so you I would push you on
that story and say what are they doing
in the US that allows them to get that
growth rate maybe they're offering
something that us consumers don't have
right now so PDD our argument is it's a
big story because it's a company in a
market which is moderate growth China
grow China's growth is moderated but it
has the capacity to go Global right what
about
margins what what's its business how
does it make
money they have higher maret
they
selling are they selling or they intered
Alibaba is an intermediary right you
just connect customers to stores and
they keep a percent PDD is similar in
terms of how it makes money it's a
transaction every time there's a trans
which is a high margin business because
you basically are an intermediary you
connect you know customers so you growth
you got your margin St we can finish
your valuation right now to grow what
does PDD have to
do remember You' told two-thirds of your
story already right you talked about
growing where in other markets so the
reinvestment year will either have to
take Acquisitions in other markets to
get an entry there or some kind of
investment platform customer acquisition
cost depending on the part of the world
that could be different from their
reinvestment in
China and finally on a cost to Capital
basis this is ultimately a business
that's built around whether the economy
is doing well how much retail sales
there are it is going to be a
discretionary business in that sense it
doesn't mean the revenues are going to
drop off the cliff you have a story for
PDD that's going to translate to numbers
and you're going to Value the
company anybody else want to volunteer
their company we'll tell you a story
right now what's the company of
value now we're in trouble I've no so
there's a Polish male Service Company so
they're like US mail for for Poland that
was was it privatized
a that's an unusual company to Value
what led you to to that okay so they s
so but are they primary so let's start
with the story are they only Poland
based okay so they are looking so your
growth story will include the fact that
they're in Poland right now but that
they can take this concept to is there
any competition for this kind of thing
in the UK with the places they're going
okay so that'll set
okay so they have this niche market to
themselves they're going to expand
geographically now how do they make
money do they you pay per box or how
does it work in terms of how they make
money okay so there is a so it's driven
by what the merchants are willing to pay
them so building to a story and in the
risk here in that story of course is
that there's going to be some kind of a
technological disruption that leads
people to to pick something else to use
but it's a base story it's a core story
it's not going to be a soaring growth
story because it will require investment
right you got to build these so it will
require more reinvestment than PDD will
so it's a story that those pieces will
play out in your Revenue growth your
margins your sales to Capital ratio and
ultimately the more ambitious you get
the more negative your cash flows will
become right so I want you to think
about your company trans start thinking
about the story before you open the
Excel spreadsheet don't do the Excel
spreadsheet first first and then reverse
engineer story because you're missing
the
point you want to think about the story
that drives your company so let's say
you've told a story for your company are
you
done still 3 weeks away from April 4th
can things happen in 3 weeks you've
lived through the last two weeks
right the next three weeks who knows
what tomorrow will bring and the day
after so let's say what might cause your
story to
change could your story
change because your company comes out
with an earnings report can an earnings
report change a
story give me an example what kind of
news in an earnings report will change a
story see fantastic or terrible doesn't
tell me much right that that often is
you have to show me there's something
happening in your business that I did
not expect maybe you're entering into
geography so V can and they say they're
expanding in the US that's what the
earnings report they might not make much
money and all of a sudden my story gets
very different because I've added a
geography that's a really big geography
to their Market with a very it might not
increase the value but it Chang so in
earnings reports you're not looking at
that earnings per share number as much
as what goes into it where are they
growing where are they failing what
happens to their margins and earnings
report can change your story more so if
you're a young company than if you're a
mature company
second could a
macroeconomic change affect you saw the
inflation news this morning right came
it slightly lower than expected he
saying who cares there are some
companies are extremely exposed to
inflation so when you get the inflation
news it's a macron news it can affect
evaluations as well you're a Canadian
Lumber Company the last two weeks have
been a Rawl looking ride right not
because of anything that happened in the
company but because you have tariffs and
talkx counter tariffs and you're saying
what the heck do we
do macroeconomic changes can affect what
about regulatory
changes especially for a subset of
companies that are very very dependent
on regulation the change in the
regulation can affect your
value could an earning support from
another company affect your
value when lift reports
earnings could Uber's story be affected
yeah because there in the same business
if something is affecting one company it
can spill over in another company so you
see the bad news here right you told a
story today who knows what that story
will look like three weeks from now
because things can change your story is
going to constantly
shift now you might think that's
unsettling I I like my story to settle
down but to me this is what makes
valuation interesting you're never quite
done the story keeps evolving one final
question
remember the corporate life cycle I
talked about young companies middle-age
companies old
companies valuations are always a
balance between stories and numbers but
I want you to think about how that
balance changes as you go
through stripe is going you know is a
payment processing young company in
valuing stripe you can look at the
financials but much of your value is
going to be driven by a story impost is
still still young much of your value is
going to be driven by the story you
tell in contrast you're valueing
Coca-Cola what's going to matter more
numbers or
Story the numbers are basically going to
drive your value because the story I
mean the way I like to think about this
is somebody's writing a
book and they die and they've called you
in to finish the book I know morbid
thought but the author was in chapter
one when he died it's a 35 chapter
book you can write the story you want
right that's a young company in contrast
if you're Coca-Cola you're in chapter 23
of a 35 chapter book the characters are
already wandering around you can't
introduce new things to do the story has
been pretty much
told if you're craft hand you're in
chapter 34 of a 35 chapter book you're
writing the ending when you look at
mature companies much of the story is
older doesn't mean the story can't
change but it's not going to change as
dramatically as when you look at a young
company so the reason I think for a long
time analysts were able to get away
without telling stories is for a long
time in public companies the typical
company valued was a company with an
established business model a mature
companies you could get away without
being a
Storyteller today you look at companies
like palente here it's not an option you
have to learn to tell stories so I'm
going to go back to where I left you on
the storytelling if you remember we
talking about
impossible
implausible and improbable
valuations remember the Uber story I
told you Urban Car Service Company
attracts new users local networking
benefits doesn't own the cars keeps 20%
the fair that's the 2014 story is it
possible yeah it's not an big uplifting
story I'm telling a story what they're
already doing right they're old an urban
car service
company the part of the world where
they've been in the longest the Bay Area
the car service business had already
doubled in the 5 years they'd been there
why did it double so much because people
stopped buying cars because Ubers and
lifts were so easy to
find and they were getting 20% of the
Affairs and not owning the cars so this
story is very easy to defend because it
is a story where I've not gotten
ambitious could I have told a different
story in 2014 for Uber yeah I could have
told you a much bigger story but if I
did that the onus is on me to try to
explain why the biggest the bigger my
story gets the more defense I should be
playing because I have to justify all
these parts of The
Story So Stories lead to numbers numbers
lead to Value right so let's say you're
an
investor I'm going to give you a warning
about a story you might run into I call
it a runaway story what's a runaway
story a story that sounds so good you
want it to be
true here are the ingredients that
usually go into runaway story usually
there's a charismatic Storyteller
somebody you really like or
admire second they're telling a story
about disrupting a business you've never
ever
liked and third along the way they're
going to make the world a better place
come on don't you want the story to be
true I'll tell you a story you tell me
whether you want the story to be true
it's about a 19yearold
who drops out of Stanford who does that
you know how difficult it is to get in
their what is the admission rate was
minus
3% unless you're of course a rhythmic
gymnast who came in through the side
door but that's a different
story who drops out so this 19yearold
drops out of Stanford to start a new
business your reaction is another
techque starting another software
business this is where the story takes a
turn this 19-year-old is not a tech
geik or a male it's a female she drops
out and she starts a blood testing
business and she's going to
revolutionize this
business how many of you had experiences
with the blood testing business in the
US anytime in the last few
years he experiences happy exuberant how
would you describe this
experience not not too fun that's
exactly the word I would
use you call and you set up an
appointment for a blood test and they
say
well it's 6: a.m. 4 weeks from now is
there something at a more reasonable
time well we have an opening 2 years
from now okay I'll take the 6: a.m. 4
weeks from now you show up at 6:00 a.m.
they make you wait for 2 hours why
because they
can 8 a.m. the doors open and the nurse
comes out of the room she looks like
nurse ratchet from one floor with the
CUO Nest she said come on in your knees
start knocking terrified you walk in you
notice two buckets next to her what are
those for your
blood why do you need two buckets of my
blood just in case Dracula shows up I
guess she extracts half your blood and
Ne make you drag yourself out of the
room you drive home and nothing you he
nothing for the blood testing company so
2 weeks later you call them and say I
want the results of my test said we
can't give you the results why why not
privacy it's my
blood we'll send your results to the
doctor you can go talk to him or her so
you call the doctor 6:00 a.m. 4 weeks
from now this game you already played so
you say Okay show up 6:00 a.m. they make
you wait 2 hours you walk into the
doctor's office he's looking at your
blood test looking very
troubled so after about 10 minutes of
letting you kind of
worry he says there's nothing wrong with
you
so why did you just say that right off
the top because I wanted to torture you
so you take the results home but no the
story is not over because four weeks
later what do you get you get a bill in
the mail for $1,500 that the insurance
company wouldn't
cover no wonder we hate the blood
testing business and what she going to
do she's going to revolutionize the
business instead of two buckets she's
going to take two drops of your blood in
nanot tainers not bucket sounds already
21st century right
she's going to test the blood for 32
different things I don't even name some
of them but they're very technical
names 45 minutes later she's going to
email you the
results and the whole thing is going to
cost you $100 come
on and oh I forgot to say she's also
going to give these blood tests away
free to parts of the world people can't
afford the blood test and you're going
to save tens of millions of
people in the process don't you want the
story to be true I
did this is of course the true story of
Elizabeth Holmes and terros she drops
out of Stanford starts a
company by the middle of 2015 tanos was
priced by venture capitalist at $9
billion but it wasn't just VCS who got
excited the Cleveland Clinic one of
America's leading Healthcare
organization said this is a great blood
testing business what Walgreens which at
that time was a healthy Pharmacy said
we're going to have a teros lab in every
Walgreens so if you'd ask me in the
middle of 2015 what I thought about
Theos my response would have been I
don't know much about the company $9
billion pricing Walgreens Cleveland
Clinic there must be something there I
assume that somebody somewhere along the
way would have asked the question which
is it's a blood testing company
right does your blood test work
and in October of 2015 a Wall Street
Journal reporter asked exactly this
question and the results were actually
in the public domain because as a blood
testing company you got to go to the FDA
you got to file your results he went to
the FDA and said hey teros claims to run
these 32 tests from their nanot tainers
how many of those tests have they been
approved to do the FDA said we've
approved them for one but not the other
31 he said why he said the results are a
little noisy
you know what a noisy blood test looks
like trust me you don't want it result
comes back and say you might be dying
you might not don't worry about it go
home and we'll let you know blood test
you want Precision you don't want
noisiness and in the next 6 months the
entire company
unraveled 6 months later the pricing had
gone to zero Elizabeth Holmes had been
banned from the blood testing business
for 3 years there was a criminal case
working its way through that fin got
resolved last year when she was sent to
jail I think for 10
years but in October of 2015 when this
happened I wrote a post because
everybody said that's stupid why would
somebody ask that question I said let's
let's roll the tape back and go back to
June of 2015 when Elizabeth Holmes came
to New York to give a talk she was a
celebrity why because she was under 30
she'd become a billionaire started her
own business people had brought their
daughters so they could see sixcess play
out I said if you'd been in that meeting
where Elizabeth Holmes was the celebrity
speaker would you have had the courage
to get up and ask the question does your
blood test work you'd have felt like the
guy who shot Bambi's mother I've always
felt badly for that guy have you ever
seen Bambi go back and watch the movie
it's the first 10 minutes bamb Bambi's
mother gets shot by a hunter the hunter
you never see he's just background but
he must have gone through all kinds of
trauma after that
movie you'd have felt you were killing
six-year-old dreams asking that question
there's an intimidation Factor when
everybody around you is convinced that
this is the greatest thing ever there's
an intimidation factor in asking Common
Sense
questions runaway stories are more
common than you think I remember in 2019
a company called wework filed for an IPO
somebody described to me what the wew
work business model is what do they do
rent out on space before you rent it out
first you got to get the space right how
do they get the
space they either buy it or they sign a
long-term lease so you sign a 40-year
lease and where the sites usually
located the most expensive parts of the
city you look at we work buildings that
in Prime real estate so you've signed
expensive real estate for 40 years then
what do you
do people don't have offices bus
a service right if you're a small
business you don't want to rent an
office for the next 10 years you want
rent for the next 3 months it's great
for young startups so you basically
lease for 40 years and subase out for
two months 3 months four months you see
a problem with this model it's a
duration mismatch made in hell right and
it's never worked in real estate because
you know what brings it down a recession
minute you have a recession what happens
all your short-term leases leave your
building empties out and you're still
stuck with 40 Years of lease payments so
when we work in public I was
curious I was initially going to give
them the benefit of the doubt why what
is it about we work that gave them
instant
credibility Newman is the Ted X speaker
right by himself I'd have said another
Ted X speaker who is the biggest
investor in
weor a guy called masas who was viewed
as a Visionary perhaps almost at the
level of a
God but maybe not very close to it he
had a 300-year plan you know who makes
300E
plans arrogant people who think they
they have a God complex but he was
viewed in 2019 as a genius investor so
people said if he is backing it he must
have asked Adam Newman the CEO of the
company the question of how do you make
this
work so when they filed for an IPO I
went through their prospectus 4 11 pages
on the prospectus you know what I was
looking for that secret formula they
were using to fix this duration mismatch
I get to page 41 no mention of
it I valued the company afterwards and I
said look I don't care who the great
investors are this is a duration
mismatch made in hell I don't see a way
of fixing it and I heard from somebody
in weor saying but we do this on
hundreds of buildings what happens to a
bad model when you multiply thousand
fold it becomes a really big bad model
right it doesn't become a good
model and of course in the case of wew
work the whole thing spun down to zero
very very quickly partly because of
their arrogance but my point about
runaway stor is sometimes people pile on
nobody wants to stop and ask the
question remember the story of The
Emperor's New
Clothes you haven't you haven't heard
the story is Emperor has no clothes but
he tells the town's people that the only
people who can see his clothes are
really smart
people what a great Ploy actually the
tayor tells him to tell the crowd so
even the emperor thinks he's wearing
clothes because he looks it doesn't look
like I'm wearing clothes and the Taylor
says if you're really brilliant you can
see your clothes Emperor looks I see all
my clothes now so for weeks all the
town's people convince them so Emperor
is wearing clothes Emperor is wearing
because if they said they turn to their
neighbor and said I don't see the
clothes that me admission I'm not really
smart so who gives away the
game a 5-year-old kid says the emperor
is
naked hey we need that happening more
right because these companies often it's
somebody who's naive who says I don't
get this KKR and Blackstone might think
this is an amazing idea but this just
doesn't make
sense one final point when I wrote my
post on on uh teros I did look at the
board of directors there were a private
company but that a board of directors I
said how did they get along and I looked
looked at the names before I looked at
the names I looked at the last column I
said this is an amazing Ploy if you're a
CEO doesn't ever want to be asked a
question you know what you should do
pick a bunch of 70 or 80 year olds make
them directors in your company call them
for a board meeting but put pillows in
front of every chair have an ambulance's
backup your board meetings will go
really quickly unless you have a
casualty and then you look at names on
the board what the heck is Henry
Kissinger doing on the board of
directors for a blood testing
company guy's 92 years
old maybe he's talking about the Iron
Curtain and getting blood out of the
Iron Curtain this is so this is clearly
a board that is connected you see that
that's basically what this is you have
George Schulz on there ex Secretary of
State you had now I I think it was um
Mattis James matters who was the
Secretary of Defense between 2016 and
2018 connections to governments to
defense contractors weird board for a
for a blood testing company but it's
very
connected so watch out for runaway
stories because some of you might have a
company where you really really really
want the story to be true at which point
you stop asking yourself questions it
kind of sails
through so when you think about what
causes runaway stories to melt down
first that charismatic Storyteller you
discover has feet of clay they do
something and you say well I don't try
you know what gave Adam Newman away he's
the CEO of we work is when you looked at
the Prospectors they actually had a
clause there that I was so unbelievable
that I'd read it three times to make
sure I read it right if you have a
publicly traded company and he was
CEO how do who replaces the CEO of a
publicly company if they're
incapacitated they have a stroke or they
die who usually does that in a publicly
company It's usually the board of
directors right they come up with
suggestions that's a typical in the case
of we work you know what the clause in
the prospector said would happen if Adam
Newman got
incapacitated his wife Rebecca
Newman would pick the next CEO what is
this a royal family
that shows a level of arrogance though
right where you know you that people
would not even push
back I've never read a more arrogant T
Prospectors than the one put out by weok
they were so convinced that they were
above the freay that nobody ask them
questions that they just Expos
themselves and and afterwards you saw
stories about how he baned shoes do you
know that in we work headquarters Adam
Newman demanded that people not wear
shoes God help people have athletes
foot you you know so he put in these
requ and you read about say well maybe
this guy is not the great Storyteller
that I thought it was was second the
story is at war with the numbers so when
they tell you we can do this the story
doesn't match up to the numbers you're
seeing for the company and third your
basic business model is a bad model
expanding it just makes it an even worse
model in the last decade more and more
companies with those ingredients were
able to go public and eventually they
crash and burn but during the period
when they're regarded as great companies
you can have tens of billions of dollars
of
value this is a Side Story here about
what happens when you find a really big
Market call it the big Market
delusion let's suppose that a big Market
opens up like what China in its early
days AI now in the 1990s it's a big
market right it's beckoning saying come
on in you're an entrepreneur you see
this big Market you want to start a
business I want to step back here and
ask you a question if if you know
entrepreneurs you hung out with them do
they tend to be overconfident people or
diffident
people you're an
entrepreneur what makes you an
entrepreneur you think you can pull off
this flush
and you can pull it off you generally
tend to be an overconfident person which
is not bad right we need overconfident
people so you start a business going
after this big Market where do you get
your money from venture capitalist
venture capitalist they tend to be
overconfident people or defent people
extraordinar overconfident because they
think they can pick the winner so now
you have an overconfident entrepreneur
surrounded by three overconfident
venture capitalist looking at a really
big Market how does this play out when I
ask you what can you company do and you
project out your revenues and margins
you give me these really big numbers
because you're convinced you're going to
be the
winner but this is a big market right
there are 100 clusters just like yours
all over the world they're all aiming
for the same big Market they're all
overconfident people over overestimate
you see where this is going right if I
add up the values at each of these
clusters attaches to itself what's going
to be true about the sum of the values
it's going to be too high I call this
the big Market delusion and it happens
every single time I saw it in the 1980s
with the PC business in the 1990s with
the
business social media and online
advertising same phenomenon play in fact
with the with social with when online
advertising was taking off I took the
big online advertising companies I took
their market cap and reverse engineered
what their revenues would have to be 10
years out to justify the market cap and
I added up the numbers and I got a total
Market that was 50% larger than the
actual existing
Market you think this is crazy this is
irrational no it's absolutely
human every time you have a big Market
you will overvalue the market there will
eventually be a correction and when that
happens what do we call it the do com we
called it the dot crash and then we all
ring our hands say never
again and then Regulators say we want to
stop this from happening let's pass
rules it is part of markets you don't
like the chaos then don't go looking for
markets would you want to live in a
world run by
actuaries you know where we still be in
caves this fire thing that is not tested
yet a few thousand more years then we'll
get out of the cave every advanc in
humankind has come from people
overreaching
right so before we complain about there
will be an AI crash there will be people
who complain about it but remember the
crash did it change that that doom boom
and crash change the way we
live we put it differently when was the
last time any of you actually walked
into a physical travel agency you know
there used to be these places like you
know big big offices where seven or
eight people sat in front of computers
you'd go in and say I want to go to
Chicago they they say okay let me give
let me look at the secret sauce they
wouldn't let you look at the terminal I
found the perfect flight for you it'll
cost you
$420 but you got to book it through us
right
now I hope none of you are doing that
anymore right you go to Travelocity you
go to Expedia you go on Google
flights every one of these B these
crashes has changed the way we live
there will be an AI crash because we
will overreach
but it'll still change the way we do
things we chat GPT might be doing things
for us that we don't do today so I call
this the big Market delusion because
every time you see a market right now
it's AI 10 years from now who I don't
know what it'll be but even in the 40
years I played it I've seen four big
markets roll through and every single
time this
happens one final example before we
leave this second this phase of
Storytelling is it possible is it
plausible is it it probable right so
Tesla is a company I valued every year I
think the first time I valued was in
2013 for the first six years that I
valued I consistently found it
overvalued and I missed some ingredients
that later came into play with Tesla so
this is in very early valuation
2014 I'd done a valuation of Tesla on my
blog I remember I came up with the value
of 100 billion which was high by those
by the standards of the day given how
few C were were selling but Tesla has
had this fortune or Misfortune of Being
of being followed by equity research
analysts who are True Believers in what
in
Tesla so they're not equity research
analysts they're advocates for Tesla so
this was one of the biggest names in
equity research following Tesla he's
still around I won't name him because I
might shame him so he put out a
valuation and his value was three times
higher than mine and I was curious about
what he was assuming about Tesla that I
was missing so I read his equity
research report first it's 150 pages
long it's a creative novel there lots of
pictures I don't know even of
what and then on page 73 there was a d.
c.f that's what he called it so I'm
going to stay with this terminology he
said this is our d. c.f I said okay this
is the place I live you take a look at
the numbers so I took a look at the
numbers this is his d. c.f I'm going to
go through remember the the exercise we
went through this morning for first I
start with the revenue number and he's
projecting lots of growth in fact he
estimates that the number of cars Tesla
will sell will go from 24,000 which is
what they sold in the previous 12 months
to 1.1 million first is that
possible Right how big is a car market
how many cars get sold in a typical year
across the
world it's an unfair question how the
heck would anybody know we probably
should be checking Google Search right
now it's about 80 to 85 million cars get
sold here so 1 million is entirely
plausible so I said okay that was
actually pretty close to what I was
estimating so I'm a little puzzled
because he's estimating roughly the same
number of cars but he's getting a value
three times higher so maybe he's
assuming technology company margins on
cars you can get there right 35 40
software compan no he was doing his
margins were actually a little lower
than mine he had nebit margin not nebit
margin it's actually so now I'm
befuddled he's selling as many cars as I
thought I you know Tesla would and his
margins are a little lower his value is
Three Times Higher and then I looked at
his reinvestment saying how do you get
reinvestment see this earnings number he
called it net income but it's like an
after tax operating income and the free
cash flow number what's the difference
between the know what accounts for ebit
Time 1 minus t minus free cash flow
what's the intermediate
steps plus depreciation minus it's the
reinvestment number right so I added up
his earnings numbers for the next 15
years and his free cash FL numbers for
the next 15 years and looked at the
difference that's a collective
reinvestment you know what the
collective reinvestment of the next 15
years was close to
zero Houston we have a
problem the number of cars is going to
go from 24,000 to 1.1 million in 2013
Tesla had one Factory in Fremont which
on a really good day at a capacity of
250,000
cars you see what the problem is where
is the other 800,000 cars going to come
from so I called the equator research
analyst he was in New York airport
catching a flight to California I think
he was going to worship at a Tesla
Shrine I don't know what he was going to
do and I said I'd like to talk about
your equity research report and he said
I can't answer very many questions
because you know those numbers know
there's a team that works I said there's
a team that turned out this d. c.f I
wanted to make sure you use the same
terminology wouldn't get confused said
yeah team of six I said
okay can I call you next week he said
you can call me next week I'll be back
with the team and I said okay I'll call
you and he said you're not going to
write about this on your blog or
anything right I said not for the next
week but then all bets are off so I call
him the next week the team had gathered
together so the lead analyst comes on
and he says look I'm the lead
analyst but yeah I don't really work
with the numbers I said what do you do
you know he described what he did and
basically shooed a lot you know shmoo is
the very New York word you just go chat
with people talk with people he schmoo
with the management schmoo he was a
chief schmoozer so his second in command
comes in say what do you do he says I go
with that guy I'm the secondary
schmoozer there the third guy what do
you do I'm the backup schmoozer one of
these two guys can't smoo I'm the one
who steps head I said who in this team
does something other than
Shmo they pointed to a 23y old an they
hired out of warten the previous year
said he is the guy I feel sorry for him
he's on the spot he's responsible for
this D
docf we go through and he gets it very
quickly I said you realize there's a
problem here right there's capacity of
250,000 you're selling 1.1 million cars
you haven't set aside any reinvestment
to
build assembly
plans he said it slipped my mind I said
what slipped your mind he said the way I
got the capex and depreciation for
future years was I took the numbers from
the last year but there wasn't much
didn't build a factory and I just
projected it
out he said don't you think it's a aam
he said yes but I don't see how we go
public with this how do we tell the
world we forgot to put in assembly
plans I didn't have an easy answer for
him but I did have a suggestion which he
did not take he said have you ever seen
this movie willly Wonka's chocolate
factory
he said no but one of the older analysts
had with Jean Wilder and I said you
might want to rewatch that movie because
I remember watching that movie when I
was much much younger and a big question
that movie Willy won has one Chocolate
Factory it's a very inefficiently laid
out factories like chocolate Rivers
riding and my big question coming out of
the movie is bully Wonka chocolates are
all over the world how the heck does
this one Factory produce enough
chocolates to ship part of the rest of
the world and the answer is actually in
the movie there are these creatures
called Oompa loomas if you get a chance
type in the word Oompa looma in Google
there these know tiny they they just
dance around as they dance around candy
comes flying out of the factory I said
here's what you need to do put out a
news
release that Tesla has fired all of its
existing workers in the Fremont plant
and replace them with Oompa Loompas
your problem is gone away I call these
Oompa Loompa valuations or you can call
them whatever these are valuations we
have these great plans for growth but
nothing is being built to deliver that
growth so impossible implausible
improbable don't take anybody's
valuation at face value including mine
your job is to be skeptical to ask those
questions to make sure this qu this
valuation passes that test so now I'm
ready to convert my Uber story into
numbers the advantage of my framework is
it's parsimonious there only three
things that drive cash flows Revenue
growth margins reinvestment or sales to
Capital there are only two things would
capture risk your cost to Capital and a
failure risk so here's what I'm going to
do I'm going to take each part of my
Uber story and make it into number how
do I describe Uber urban car service
company right so the first step was
actually coming up with a size for that
market how big
where would I get this
information I'll tell you in 2014
nowhere why because this business in
2014 was hopelessly splintered who
dominated this business around the world
taxi cab companies they were not
publicly traded you know what I had to
do I had to go City by City New York
City has a taxi and limousine commission
they actually track how much taxi cabs
make I had to go City by City And after
about 50 cities I got tired I was at 50
billion so I doubled the number and I
made that the market size to show you
why you should never trust Google so I
put that out there with my valuation six
months later I go on Google and say
maybe there's a better number out there
size of the urban car service Market on
Google search guess what shows up as
number one find Dem modance 100 bit if
only you knew what I did and how I got
there you wouldn't be using this number
but I had to start and basically that's
the best I could do like gets easier
when you're doing the retail business
right why because many of them are
publicly traded you can add up the
revenues of publicly traded retail
companies in the public domain if you
have a business that's entirely
privately structured it gets much
Messier there'll be numbers you will
find on Google search I don't know how
much you can trust them but this was my
starting point that market had been
growing at about 2% years a slow growth
Market over the previous 5 years but my
story what do I assume that Uber will
attract people like my son and my niece
into a business who would never have
taken a taxi Gap so I made the 2% growth
into 6%
growth I've good so that's the total
market now I've got to give Uber a
market share of that market right do you
remember the third part of my story
local networking benefits that Uber
would end up dominating a city but
there'd be other right sharing companies
that dominate other cities in my story
no company no right sharing companies
going to have a 50% market share of the
global market so I gave them a 10%
market share huge by car service
standards but not
dominant let's keep going on I have my
revenues I need margins what is Uber do
it's got a computer it connects cars to
customers this is a high margin business
you should be able to get amazing Unity
economics on that 20% that you collect
so I gave the margins of 40% reflecting
their intermediation
model and finally when I looked at risk
oh before I go to risk for the rein
investment since they don't own the cars
they should be able to grow with
relatively little
reinvestment platforms maybe computers
so I gave them a sales to Capital ratio
of five which is twice the average for
us companies saying hey this is a low
Capital intensity company it can grow
with very little
reinvestment almost every part of my
story is now an
input then I got to the cost of capital
so how many sessions did we spend on
cost of capital we started with that
dance on risk freed rate Equity risk
premium bottom of B don't forget any of
that stuff but when you're Val a company
like uber that is not the hill you want
to die
on is Uber a risky company in 2014
absolutely so here's what I did to get a
cost of capital I have a histogram of
cost of capital for all global companies
I went to the 90th percentile the cost
of capital was
11.97% and I rounded it 12% and made
that my cost of capital took me 2
minutes but let's it the big Focus here
has to be on revenues and market share
not on the cost of Capital One final
question could Uber have failed given
the numbers in 2014 they're a small
company losing a lot of money Venture
capitals don't provide the capital they
would so I gave them a 10% failure rate
why so low because in a sense they're
too big to fail what is too big to fail
now if you're a venture capital you
invest in a $7 billion company you'll be
more real reluctant to let that $ 17
billion company crash and burn than a
$17 million company because if it
crashes and burns what do you have to do
you have to write off that investment in
your portfolio you have to tell your
investors that you lost a lot of money
so in a strange way being this big makes
that failure risk lower I've taken every
single
number here and connect to the
story here's my value of uber looks like
an Excel spreadsheet but every number in
the sheet comes from my story so we ask
ask me why my revenues 3.6 billion in
year 10 it's because Uber is an urban
car service company with local
networking benefits why am I margin 40%
because an intermediation company that
makes money by connecting cars to
customers why is there reinvestment so
low because they don't own the cars why
is my cost of capital so high because
they're a risky
company every number has a story backing
and based on my numbers the value that I
got for Uber was about 6
bilon I posted this the new The Wall
Street Journal story came out on June
4th of 2014 I spent that entire week
obsessing about Uber Friday that on June
8th at about 3:15 I post this on my blog
15 minutes later I get a call from a
Wall Street Journal reporter she must
have been waiting at her desk for this
to come through she said I noticed you
valued Uber I said thank you for
noticing he said I also noticed you
attached a value of 6 billion I said
you're very observant
she said you do know that Venture
capitals a value the company at 17
billion I almost corrected her there
with what ADV venture capitalist price
companies I don't value them but I cut
her some slack she's a journalist I said
okay yeah she said how do you explain
the 17 billion I said I don't have to I
didn't pay it I've never felt the urge
to explain what other people pay you
know how much frustration this has saved
me in my life said how do you explain
the 995,000 people 95,000 that people
are paying for bit co go ask somebody
who paid the 95,000 why are you asking
me she said are you telling me they're
wrong I said I'm telling you nothing of
the sort maybe they have a bigger story
for Uber than I do why do you ask them I
don't own The High Ground here I have a
story that story gives me a number the
number gives me a value the value drives
my
decision but I'm not going to convince
you that my number is what do I care
it's your money right I'll give you my
story you can make it yours you can
change the things that you don't like
but essentially I always view valuation
as my valuation reflecting my story for
the company it's not the story for the
company and the
valuation so I finished the
valuation I posted my blog I think I'm
done but right after I post the blog I
get emails from four different places
asking whether they can take my blog
post and run it on their site the first
was a site called 538.com you heard of
it 538.com was founded by Nate silver
used to be the New York Times pollster
it's a statistics key it's a fun side if
you like questions like you know how
they have a hot hand in basketball
legend they take things like that is
there truly a hot hand so they take
urban legends they test them with the
data so the editor of the site called me
and she said can I run this because our
readers our not numbers people and
they'd like this I said be my guest so
she the whole post the second place I
got a call from was the Forbes blog who
reads the Forbes blog usually 75 year
olds with flip phones I think it's a
very old value invest very different
audience and I said yeah go ahead the
third place that called was a site
called
Tech heard
Tech it's actually a technology it's a
digital magazine for Silicon Valley
people
and jaap is they said we'd love to run
this because people here are interested
said go ahead and the final call I got
was from a guy called from a site called
the right sharing guy still around type
in right sharing guy it's run by a guy
called Harry Campbell and he writes for
Uber and lift
drivers there almost a couple of million
of them around so he has a big audience
he said can I run this because my Uber
drivers would be really interested in
the valuation of uber same post four
different sites I get four very
different sets of feedback on the 538
side here's the kind of question I get I
read your post I noticed you told us
that you use the 90th percentile of your
histogram but that's 11.97% and you're
using 12%
why and I said why don't you take the
Excel spreadsheet take the 12% replace
it with 11.97% and see what happens 5
minutes later I get email saying I see
why you did what you did nothing
happened so not much it's second decimal
points a lot of tech geek question math
geek
questions the Forbes blog loved it they
said this is the way those tech people
should be valuing companies I spend no
time on that
side the tech crunch guys not tech tech
crunch guys absolutely hated it their
response was how dare you value one of
ours with your d. c.f we don't do that
in Silicon
Valley like 400
comons 50 were pure insults most of
which I didn't quite get one said you
DCF guy and read and said what does that
mean is that good is that bad but the
other 150 started with an insult you
idiot let me tell you how surge pricing
works at
Uber and this is a tech engineer who
worked at Uber he said this is how we
track people and let's face it I don't
know those inside details I learned from
reading those comments but to read them
I had to get past the
insult and then I got to the right
sharing guys side and I learned things
about Uber I would never have learned
from their top management Uber was going
around telling investors that they kept
20% of the fair it would technically
looked like they did so an Uber driver
from La writes to me and he says I know
Uber is telling the world that they keep
20% fair but here's what's happening in
La I used to drive for lift until a few
weeks
ago Uber paid me $3,000 to
switch Now lyt is offering me 5,000 to
switch back I feel like a free agent
without a
contract and here's how he ended he said
I wouldn't be surprised of all of this
money being paid they ended up with 7 or
8% of the fair not
20% 5 years later that's what Uber
reveals to the world they're making
seven or 8% contribution margin the
biggest cities and my reaction was I
knew that already your La driver told
me this is the feedback loop and it
actually came to you know Crescendo
about two or three weeks after I write
this
post I was in Munich Airport waiting for
a connecting flight and it's
delayed so while I'm waiting I'm
checking my email and I see an email
from a guy called Bill Gurley for those
of you who don't know Bill he's a
partner at benchmark Capital Benchmark
capital is a VC firm that was one of the
first VC firms to invest nuba they
invested a billion dollar
pricing Bill actually was the was on the
board of directors ruber rumored to be
the person closest to Travis gnik who
was the
CEO let me ask you an easy question does
Bill Gurley know more about Uber than I
do absolutely I see the email I open it
here's how it goes he says I read your
post on Uber and I did not like like it
I said okay we got that out of the way
he said I've written my post to counter
your post it's blog post to blog post
Warfare very 21st
century and I've said some mean things
about you and I just wanted to let you
know
sincerely
bill so I close the email I've got an
hour and a half for my flight guess
where I go next I go to Bill's blog it's
called above the crowd he's 6' 6 in
above the crowd no
and basically took issue with every part
of my story he said Uber is not a Car
Service Company it's a logistics company
notice how words have consequences what
do logistics companies do they do car
service they do moving they do delivery
he said we're not just Urban we're going
to be everywhere give examples of how
Uber PL to go to rural areas Suburban
areas and then finally he
said we're going to take our dominance
of cities like New York and London which
you already have and we're going to
partner with Airlines and with credit
card companies so when you fly from New
York to Jakarta and United after you
make the reservation there'll be little
box at the bottom that says do you want
an Uber car waiting for you in Jakarta
very clever way of saying if we dominate
a city we're going to that local benefit
we're going to
globalize so like six pages he didn't
mention a single number I read the thing
I'm fascinated by a story along the way
he took a few swipes at me most of which
were true he said this deoderant guy has
never taken an Uber that was a lie taken
one Uber
right he doesn't know the technology of
right sharing guilty is
charged but at the end I know I'm
sitting there Munich Airport I write to
Bill and I say I read your post it's
fascinating would you like me to put a
number on your story he said what are
you talking about I said you told a big
story for Uber I can convert to Value he
said be my guest and here's what I did I
took my valuation and I took that total
Market of 100 billion the car service
Market and I tripled it include moving
and delivery much bigger Market that 10%
market share local networking benefits
if his story is true the world will be
dominated by two or three right sharing
companies not 10 so I can give Uber at
40% market share you change those
numbers what you get is a value is 53
billion for the company I sent him the
value still sitting in Munich
Airport and I said do you like this more
he said a
lot and he said oh by the way it's 20%
shares not long for the world probably
get lower I almost told him your La
driver told me that already I said
that's easy to fix tell me what it's
going to be he said about 10% so I made
it the slice 10% the value you say how
can the same company be worth 6 billion
29 or 53 billion depends on how the
story is Being Framed right you're
saying but are they all true they can't
all be true in hindsight one or the
other is going to be true but you can
see how stories as they change will
affect value towards the end of when
2014 I wrote a post again I milk this
Uber thing as much as I could I wrote a
post
nuber where I took the Builder bear
concept and I applied it to valuation
any have you seen a builder bear store
in a mall creepy little
places right you take your
seven-year-old in they give them a piece
of skin and in the next 30 minutes you
have the ugliest looking bear on the
face of the Earth and then they do a
very sneak thing they come up to you and
your six-year-old and they say you know
what you don't have to buy the bear but
if you do it'll cost you $75 I can
guarantee you not leaving that store
without the bear so I said let's build a
valuation of uber because I got sick and
tired of people bitching and mourning
about what they didn't like about my
story I said My Story my value my money
you don't like my story make it yours so
at each stage I let people pick their
own story is Uber uh Logistics comp A
Car Service Company an on demand company
saying what's an on demand company you
need something done in a hurry an on
demand company steps in the closest I
can think to a company that's an ond
demand company is goek which is a
Jakarta base it's an Indonesian company
they do moving they do delivery they
would stand in line for an Avengers
movie if you want to get a ticket and
it'll take two hours so essentially
they're arbitraging the fact that you
value your time a great deal more than
somebody else might and in countries
like India or Indonesia there's a huge
gap between what people value their time
at it's a useful idea so I said does it
have local networking benefits Global
networking benefits no networking
benefits so with each one I let people
pick their choices and at the end I say
came up with the value depending on the
choices that people pick and guess what
depending on your story your value can
be anywhere from 800 million to 90
billion doesn't mean they're all viable
but they're clearly stories which are
more plausible than others but with
young companies you can see why there's
Divergence across stories because
there's so much of the book still
waiting to be
read final component of this you tell a
story for your company the story looks
good can the story change yes it could
shift it could even
break take the story break first you
built a company let's say you're a
company that offers home work
assistance againsts
check check was a company went to $2 and
half billion doar what did they do they
hired people especially smart high
schoolers they paid them $30 an hour
which is a lot for a high schooler then
they offered homework assistant took
off but what caused that story to break
check is now Worth close to
zero now if you have a question let's
say you want to know the hypotenuse
theorem you don't have to call a human
being right you can ask Che chat GPT and
chat GPT AI has killed that
company that's a story break you thought
you had a great story until I'll give
you another example have you heard this
company called Ashley
Madison you're shaking your head really
vigorously what what did what was its
business
model no it was a cheaters Ty there are
a lot of cheaters in the world so they
connected cheaters with other cheaters
that's what Ashley Madison's model was
and I'm trying to soft bedal this so
essentially it was people cheating
cheating on their spouse with other
people cheating on their spouses it was
a great business model there are a lot
of cheaters in the world you know what
caused the model to
break one day somebody hacked a computer
and got the name of every cheater in the
world on the website and made it
public hey were politicians on there
there were actors on there overnight the
company's value imploded for good
reason stories can sometimes break
hopefully your company story will not
break in the next two months but if
you're a Canadian Lumber Company today
your story is creaking right it could
very well break if the tariffs kick
through stories can shift what does that
mean your core story stays the same but
the Contour of the story vary right your
Revenue growth could get higher your
margins could get lower and sometimes
stories can change where your company
either does something you never expected
it to do or doesn't do something that
you thought it could pull
off your story for your
company can change it can shift and some
of your stories might break in which
case what will the value of your Equity
be by the time you get to May May 5th
and you turn be worth nothing
so be ready for those changes because
they will come so I'm going to start on
actually notice we were what 14 15
sessions into this class I haven't
valued a single company info right I've
talked about it so now we're actually
going to start valuing companies and I'm
going to start
simple so I'll give you the setup what
I'm going to do so I'm going to value a
variety of companies some are going to
be mature some are going to be growth
companies some are young some are old
some are developed some are Emerging
Market but each company rather than go
through the whole valuation which is
going to be incredibly tedious I'm going
to pick on one or two aspects in every
valuation where I want you to focus and
say this is what is new about this
valuation so I'm going to tell you the
story for each of these companies I'm
going to tell you why I picked the
inputs that I did how the story connects
to inputs and they're scattered over
time there are some valuations there
that go back 20 years some that go back
2 years some are more recent so you're
going to see me change over time the
macro
environment so let's start easy right
let's start with companies that look a
lot like Bonds mature companies that pay
big dividends they're the easiest to
start let's start easy the company I'm
going to value is a company called conad
conad is the company that probably all
this power is what depend on them it's a
regulated utility somebody explained to
me how regulated utility in the US Works
what what's the
process the government gives them
Monopoly first so regulated utilities
you're given a monopoly so basically the
government says we'll be the
enforcers and we won't let competition
in and return what does the government
get Europe
Monopoly you you you come with pricing
restrictions conet raise prices has to
go in front of a legislative
committee the New York assembly and tell
them why they want to raise Power by 5%
and you know how the the regulatory
committee decides to whether to give
them a pricing increase or not they look
at the return in equity that ConEd makes
and compare it to the this is one of
those places where the capm actually has
an actual effect because the model that
you get if it says 11% you're making 10%
you might be allowed a price increase
but if you're making 15% they might say
no no price increase so regulated
monopolies you basically are getting the
benefits of no competition but you don't
get the benefits of setting prices so
that's going to play out here I'm going
to Value ConEd with a with a essentially
a stable growth dividend discount
model let me explain why remember I said
most companies free cash load Equity is
a better measure of what can be paid out
so here's what the first thing I did it
looked at how much the company was
paying out in dividends was paying out
about
73% those dividends basically are almost
equal to the free cashlo Equity this is
the rare case where a company pays out
what it can afford to in dividends so I
can say with dividends why did I decide
to use a stable growth model what's the
essence of stable growth what what
should the growth rate be less than or
equal to the risk free rate right
basically a growth rate that you can
sustain forever and if you look at the
return and equity and retention ratio
for the company remember that shortcut
their expected growth rate is about 2%
well below the risk-free rate of
4.1% so they pay out what they can
afford to in dividends they have a low
growth rate final check I ran was if
you're a stable company mature company
your cost of equity should be roughly
where the market is your beta should be
close to one and it turns out that the
beta is8 for regulated utility slightly
less than one because they're less risky
they have they meet all the ingredients
for a stable growth dividend discount so
I put in the expected dividends next
year $232 cents was the dividends last
year grow at
2.1% you divide by the cost of equity
comes from the risk free rate for the
bottom of beta and risk premium
7.7% and the value you get per share is
$42 30 you're done he saying I wish I
should have pick conad value for my
project you still
can the value is almost trivial right
dividends cost of equity growth rate the
stock was actually trading at $40 76 so
at least based on the dividend discount
model it looks slightly
undervalued let's say you have those two
numbers and you can see where it's
coming from expected dividends next year
cost of equity and growth rate I'm going
to ask a question which if you if any of
you going to end up in equity research
it's a way of taking what you've done in
this class and frame it in the language
of equity research analyst equity
research analysts love giving Target
prices Target price PR or what they
expect a Stock's price to be a year from
now in a discounted cash flow valuation
what you get is a value
today the value I'm getting today is
$423 right from the from the dividend
discount model I gave you the cost of
equ equity for the company 7.7% and I've
also given you the expected dividends
next year with those three
ingredients can you convert my dividend
discount model value per share today to
a Target price a year from
now how do I go from value per share
today to expected Target price of year
for
now what is the cost of equity it's what
I expect to make if this stock is
correctly Priced Right so in this stock
what what do I expect to make
7.7% you take the
7.7% you take 40230 grow it at
7.7% if you had no dividends that's what
the price has to be has to come entirely
from Price depreciation but because you
have dividends you can take the
dividends out your expected Target price
and you can work it out like $45
$44.50 so if you're writing an equity
research report this would be a Target
price I expect the stock to be$ 4450 and
if you go ahead and buy the stock today
at
4076 going to translate into a rate of
return well above 7.7% because the stock
is underpriced if a stock is fairly
priced it earns the expected return the
cost of equity stock is underpriced it's
going to earn more you can go Target
prices two years from now three you can
actually pull it out as long as you want
if you want to impress somebody but
basically the fact that you get a value
per share today doesn't stop you from
giving Target prices if that's the
language you want to
speak so that's a conad valuation do a
second
valuation you know what 3M
does lots of boring things right
you're thinking of their high-tech
products you know what the most
profitable 3em product
is posted not the guy who invented that
should win a Nobel
priz CU we stick it on everything right
different colors I'm a 3M investor so I
thank God for those posted notes every
day it's a company that makes a lot of
boring things that have high margins and
protected by Patent so they can keep
doing
it a company that's been around a long
time this is a valuation I did on
September 12th of 2008 in the morning
there's a reason I'm emphasizing the day
so Friday I value the
company Market is in a little bit of
turmoil the value that I got per share
was 8355 and the story I told was fairly
upbeat story a story of a company with a
brand name and these products with great
margins that would continue to do what
they're doing which is reinvest a
reasonable amount but at Great Returns
on Capital because of their brand name
and end up with a growth rate of 75% a
year not super high but it's a big
company and a mature
business and you Fay the growth out you
come up with the value the value was
$835 the stock was trading at
70 9:30 in the morning so ask me the
question every one of my valuations I'm
going to ask force you to ask me the
question if I truly believe my valuation
what should should I have been doing at
9:30 in the morning right after this
valuation I should be buying the stock
right it's significantly undervalued I
wanted to but at other things I say I'll
do it on Monday best decision I ever
made because what happened that weekend
that was the beginning of the 2008
crisis over the weekend Leman got into
trouble there was talk arlay buying it
by Monday morning that had fallen apart
lean goes under it now for the rest of
the year you are in the
crisis so this is a pre-crisis valuation
4 weeks later I returned to the
valuation things changed yeah the
numbers for the company itself hadn't
changed yet right because the financials
don't get updated but I made two big
changes one is remember the risk premium
of for and it's now up to 6% the market
this is the advantage of an implied
premium is the market is in crisis the
premium goes up second the default
spread in my debt even though the rating
hadn't changed the default spread went
up so the cost of capital reflected more
risk okay as you know so that goes into
my cost much higher cost of
capital on the numerator I was still
feeling my way around because the
numbers hadn't got updated but I knew
that the chance of a recession had
increased because of this crisis so I
reduced the growth rate from 7 and a
half% to
5% still early but I've got to make my
best test with those changes the value
per share I got was $61 $84 $61 right
undervalued still undervalued because
the price dropped even more I did buy 3M
after the crisis in fact two weeks after
that stock had dropped to 52 but when
you're in a crisis don't give up the
value will change and I hope and pray
you will not have this crisis play out
between now and May 6th and May 5th
because it could very well happen that
you could take a company today and two
weeks from now four weeks from now 6
weeks from now you could be looking at a
very different environment and the first
place to the first thing to start
changing is the equity risk premium
don't wait for me to update my implied
premium you have the spreadsheet update
the premium if there's been a
significant change in fact I sent you
the March 1st 2025 implied Equity risk
premium that feels like ages ago in
terms of time put in today's S&P 500
you're going to get a different a higher
Equity risk stream put that in update
your valuation it'll keep know and keep
your head above water here don't panic
don't kind of throw things into the dust
bin saying it's a crisis no point value
companies but I want you to bring out
this 3M valuation simply because it
shows you what a crisis can do to your
valuation even though the numbers didn't
change any
questions so here's my task for you over
the weekend I want you to start thinking
about the story for your for your
company start thinking about bringing
the Excel spreadsheet and make that
story explicit as you value a company
thanks